you are so cute is there girl you'll see
him see you I see a lot of girls hurry
onna Grande has found the perfect way to
spend her self-quarantine I see a lot of
guys too
on Monday Ari posted this recreation
from the classic Adam Sandler comedy the
waterboy I see a lot of girls I see a
lot of guys too with the help of her
victorious co-star elizabeth gillies
mariana didn't stop there she posted
another lip dub from the sandler flick
on tuesday mama I don't believe that
sort of thing personally but this time
she enlisted her mom to play Kathy Bates
role astronomy is one of the many tools
of the devil as you can see they were
even able to match the Wardrobe of each
character ariana wrote on twitter and
how'd you all make use of your day
that's a good question
and it didn't take long for the Sandman
himself to chime in
Adam quote tweeted Ariana's first post
and wrote Bobby Boucher approves of this
message and he commented on their second
clip a tough day for Bobby Vicky and
mama
[Music]